so many people go their entire lives
absolving themselves of the most
important decisions they could make of
the most important actions they could
take because that's not only what
affects you your life and your happiness
but everyone around you and ultimately
the country so I want to tell you
something here a story that occurred
this week and I you know I was talking
about this in the morning at pitch
meeting I didn't really realize this was
something that we I could tell on air
but I think was a Tim from HR I said you
know what you should talk about that so
I was at the gym this week and there's a
there's a guy in there a black guy who I
know and he's not you know he's really
black and like really black okay yeah
yeah Nubian yeah nice guy he you know
Christian guy he coaches like he coaches
basketball for underprivileged kids at a
church and we talk all the time going we
always enjoyed to this company I was
just talking with him about like
jiu-jitsu lose talking about basketball
we were kind of learning from each other
and the conversation transitioned to
politics but at one point and it started
with me I think we're talking about
athletics and the whole kind of
transgender athletics thing and so it
started with that and I talked about you
know transgender athletes and men
winning women's wrestling meets he goes
man what what is that when is this
happening that's what where have you
been I said where have you been you
don't know but you know case in Texas
it's in Texas with the father and his
son what he has to raise his boy as a
girl he was like that's that's I you
making that up cuz I know you do you
little show and I said no I do I do my
little show and it is it's fit that was
demeaning but I appreciate the way you
framed it but no this is real man I
can't believe that said yeah you really
should probably you don't leave me get
into all of us a little bit more you
know learn about it and he started
talking yes well what do you think about
politics we start talking about Bernie
Sanders and he's a cuz I know I've got
some friends who like they like Bernie
said if I really found out a lot like
what do you think so well I don't know
what do you think about a 90 percent
income tax is what what and this is how
he goes what 90 percent come on come on
who I said now 90 percent just right now
run a youtube search run ago you can see
Bernie Sanders saying that a 90% tax
wouldn't be completely out of line and
as we're talking
that's crazy this other guy comes up and
I know him he's also a good guy
Christian guy but he's a Chicago guy so
you know what that means is Chicago
Union liberal and he walks up and he's
this kind of guy who tries to bulldoze a
conversation he goes like Oh what are
you talking about Bernie's texting 90%
and I said yeah you know talking about
taxing 90% goes yeah yeah well do you
you that's because you like your roads
right away he's going to this generic
socialism argument the black isn't black
I love the black I don't use their name
so I am saying black guy so whatever you
can be offended if you want his words
you like your roads and the Black Angus
roads we call a non sequitur because
roads and goes yeah how do you think the
government's roads police department
social security incident right Social
Security Medicare Medicaid welfare
public schools DMV post office all
programs that work really well in the
black I guess yeah but they don't though
so that sets Chicago white guy off hey
shirts going nuts he goes out he starts
with Donald Trump because I don't care
what you are I'm a Christmas Donald
Trump is a horrible man because no one
treats people like that
so what treat people like what he goes
on what do you watch the news like he
kind of does it whether he's a good guy
or not I think that we have a rip-roarin
economy and we're better off because oh
oh oh a rip-roaring economy well why do
you say that I said well I don't know we
have the lowest unemployment that we've
had in decades we have the highest labor
force participation rate we have a job
surplus we have $5,000 as the median
household increased for middle-income
families not including the super wealthy
I think this is a pretty good thing and
I said also Louis black unemployment
right in the black right now it goes
like yeah yeah that's true that stress
and more black businesses being started
in Africa really he goes yeah yeah
that's true I read about that in the
novel what about to GDP that's one
second I thought I thought we want to
talk about sort of these metrics that
really affect everyday Americans you
know he's just bringing up his phone
and he brings up something about the GDP
and it didn't it wasn't really relevant
and I refuted it and pointed into
another source and he goes yeah well
that's the problem you're Republicans
only care about money I said what you
brought it up you'd run up the GDP place
so at this point yeah you were
guns only care about about your greed
and the black guy he go he turns to me
serious a lovely got a little fickle
because he turns back he goes yeah but
you kind of do though
right like you Republicans you like yeah
like a lot of white Republicans like you
know you don't really care about money
like a whole lot right nothing not real
I don't think so
cuz no I think no I really don't think
that's the case what do you mean that's
okay right now I pay half half a mind
come okay he goes yeah I said you
probably paid pretty pretty close to
that problem out because you know you're
in Texas but if you were in California
be paying close to half your income I
know that he's a pretty successful
businessperson he goes yeah okay I said
so I want to know if half isn't enough
what number is enough you tell me what
number is enough how it would pay for
all these programs that Mister Chicago
is proposing and as far as greed I would
like to know and this is an original
this is something from Thomas so old I
believe and it's been repeated I said
what I would like to know is why is it
greedy for me to want to keep more than
half but not greedy for someone else to
want to take more than half and he said
yeah that's food for thought
that's move for thought this is a good
example of is he black yester the
cultural difference is at play here and
my colorblind no it's very entertaining
to white people sometimes to listen to
black culture because food for thought
and then I don't know the Chicago guy
went on the elliptical and that was that
but the point that I'm making here is
this is a black guy who is not a
Republican at all and afterwards by the
way he took me aside later the next day
he said you know you know you talk my
dysentry she's like I think Trump is
like like I think he's like a dick but
he I do I agree what you say like I
think it's a lot I think it's better now
you start talking about that I'm going
here's the point folks sometimes
convincing people is not that hard
sometimes it just takes trying I want
people to understand this just having
those conversations in day to day life I
can't tell you how many times that's
happened that's before we've done the
show that's before if a thousands of
people line up to go to school shows and
talk about how this program or or other
programs have influenced their sort of
political walk it all started with me
having conversations with people that
the basis for change my mind sometimes
people go what why are you doing more
too why don't you do more debate but we
will do more debates when your debates
in the show but change my mind is not
about a debate change my mind is to
showcase what I just described how you
can have conversations with people in
everyday life and either convince them
or convince someone who's watching you
talk with them in other words when the
Chicago guy horned in I wasn't trying to
convince him but I knew that if I spoke
articulately if I didn't get mad if I
kept my cool and I made my points I was
speaking truthfully that the black
gentlemen would hear my point and he did
sometimes it just takes trying and when
I hear people I've heard this a lot some
people on the right you know they
complain about immigration and I do I
just have a problem illegal immigration
and as it relates to legal immigration I
do think that we should be pretty strict
on who we allow it in and we should be
picking the best and the brightest I
think we should have standard so I want
to be clear about that but sometimes you
have people who say well you know the
thing is you just look at the
demographics from people come in from
these countries black people or brown
people they vote overwhelmingly Democrat
and you know what the more you you let
come in we're just we're gonna lose a
couple never have any more conservative
principles hold on a second first of I
don't agree with the premise because
demographics are changing look at the
electoral map with Donald Trump in the
Midwestern Chicago of Chicago Michigan
Wisconsin right these states that no one
thought he had a chance in winning yours
truly included those things change but
when you say well these demographics
there's no way to change it they come in
we're gonna lose it what does that do
it absolves you of having that
conversation did I just head at the gym
did it mean that I missed a workout sure
and I was grumpy that day because if I
don't get some exercise and I'm usually
kind of prick but the point is when
someone says this is demographic problem
it meat it absolves you have any
responsibility as it relates to changing
somebody's mind and this is something
that we do a lot a lot of the time
people act as though everything is out
of their control well you know that's
just that's the way this system works
well you know it could be in your job
you know what they only they only
promote people who are the boss's son
could be in your marriage well you know
my wife is never gonna understand that
we do this a lot we act as though far
more is out of our control then I think
we give ourselves credit for it I want
to ask this is a challenge for for this
week to you which responsibilities do
you think you've been absolving yourself
oh I know I just
the grammatical phrasing audio is gonna
kill me of which responsibilities have
you been absolving yourself what do you
think maybe is something that you could
do or you should be doing but you've
made excuses that are outside of your
control so there's no way you could do
it like you know what you're never gonna
change you you're never gonna get more
than used to be 3% of the black vote
then Donald Trump came around I think
was 8 or 10 percent that's a pretty big
shift doesn't mean it's gonna be 50% but
something changed thank God that Donald
Trump and his his team didn't say we're
gonna write off the black vote thank God
thank God they didn't just say we're
gonna write off the midwestern vote they
could have done that they could have
absolved themself because you know what
there's a precedent and no one else had
done it just because no one else had
done it has done it doesn't mean that
you shouldn't try to do it and doesn't
mean that you can't do it but it's a lot
easier to tell yourself this can't be
done and I'll tell you what if you show
me what it is that you know or think you
should be doing but these
responsibilities you've been advocating
I'll show you what it is that should be
at the top of your to-do list so many
people go their entire lives absolving
themselves of the most important
decisions they could make of the most
important actions they could take
because that's not only what affects you
your life and your happiness but
everyone around you and ultimately the
country I know that not all of you have
a show like this we're really blessed
with this platform but guess what every
single one of you goes to the gym goes
to work or goes to school or as family
gatherings where these conversations can
come up and you should be doing it every
single day you should be living it every
single day no matter how daunting it may
see you may have a Thanksgiving table
filled with with nothing but the Black
Panthers and afro lesbian PhD Studies
majors and you know what one of them
could turn into Kanye West that's what
happened his dad was a black panther do
you realize that demographically that
should not exist thank God someone
didn't pass the buck and just you know
what that's that's a lost cause it's not
there are very very few lost causes if
you're convincing yourself
the case and that's why you're not doing
whatever it is that you should be doing
stop take inventory right now what is it
that you've been absolving for yourself
that you could be doing every single day
you can push this ball forward you can
move the ball you don't need me to do it
but everyone has to do it and it starts
with saying you know what it's probably
possible let me give it a whirl and then
you're not well the guys saying yeah
food for thought
food for thought I hope you enjoyed this
clip if you don't these are the ABCs of
me baby you can just click Next video
and put it in double speed of course
search doesn't necessarily work
subscriptions notifications don't
necessarily work just bookmark this page
check and we do a new video every single
day except for Sunday and if you don't
want this content to disappear join my
club at ladder with credit.com slash mug
club it's only $69 if your student
header interactive military and if you
don't you know listen I I don't want to
say that your hellbound but it it
doesn't look good for you